hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about two different types of
leprosy though this lepromatous leprosy
and tuberculosis and how they are
distinguished from each other and what
factors control the progression of
disease and both of those types let's
start by talking about what chromatids
leprosy sometimes you should purchase
l-let it is the more severe type so it's
more severe
it creates numerous skin lesions so it's
very sort of apparent that this person
has something like leprosy it's also
characterized by significant bacterial
growth and that's just because leprosy
is caused by a bacterium known as
Mycobacterium leprae and so when we say
significant bacterial growth we're
talking about a lot of this micro
bacterium now why is it more severe why
do you have more bacterial growth more
skin lesions it has to do with the type
of immune response that is occurring and
in the case of a lab there is a weaker
immune response specifically there are
two arms of the immune system one is
known as humoral one is going to cell
mediated and an El Leavitt is the
humoral immune response that is
trying to fight off this pathogen and
when we say humoral we're specifically
referring to antibodies so it's an
antibody mediated immune response and
you might say well what's the big deal
antibodies are good for us they fight
off lots of pathogens yes that's true
but Mycobacterium leprae is an
intracellular pathogen so it actually
gets inside cells and that's what
replicates and antibodies are all
extracellular so antibodies are secreted
by a certain type of cell known as a
plasma cell which is a type of B cell so
they get secreted and they are just
floating around the outside of cells and
so fall of the Mycobacterium leprae is
inside cells it can really hide from
these antibodies and that's why this is
a weaker response it's not very
effective you get this more severe form
of disease Elath is also highly
infectious to other people relative to
the other kind leprosy overall is not
actually that infectious but this is the
more infectious one of the two and it's
also sometimes called multipath Soleri
Vasiliy refers to bacillus which is the
rod shape of the micro bacterium and
molti just meaning significant bacterial
growth so there's there lots of the
micro bacterium inside the macrophages
which are the cells where they will they
can actually replicate enzyme so now
let's talk about tuberculoid leprosy
also known as T lab this is the less
severe kind it progresses more slowly
there are fewer lesions there's less
bacterial growth and overall tissue and
nerve damage and people with T lab are
fairly rare so it's it's much less
severe than the other lab why is it so
much less severe well that's because
it's characterized by a different type
of immune response and that is that
stronger cell mediated response
specifically via some a group of T cells
called cytotoxic T cells so cytotoxic T
cells also known as cd8 t-cells
sometimes referred to as killer T cells
cytotoxic T cells are ourself that will
actually kill infected cells so the
Mycobacterium leprae as it is
replicating inside a cell Sian's toxic T
cells can come along and kill that cell
stopping that replication process and
that's why it's a much more effective
immune response against this particular
pathogen so T lab has a lower end
activity to others relative to L lab
sometimes it's referred to as Posse
basilar e posse come from the Latin for
few or small so again few bacilli few
bacteria in those macrophages now you
might be asking yourself well what what
leads to L lab versus T lab because they
are the same pathogen both of them are
leprosy both of them are cousin
Mycobacterium leprae
and it turns out that what controls
whether a person develops L left or T
lab during a Mycobacterium leprae
infection what controls which type they
get is actually their genetics so a
person's particular genetic profile
which genes they have which genes are
active first its inactive is what
actually controls whether they will
proceed with a lab or a T lab and so if
you are interested in learning about
some more related topics you can check
out my playlist on epidemiology and
disease and immunology these playlists
have videos on things like antibiotic
resistant bacteria and goats
two lives and disease vectors and
antibody structure and function and a
lot of other pretty cool topics so check
those out and thanks for watching
[Music]